[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent améliorer les retraites
agricoles il y a urgence en plein
mouvement de protestation des
agriculteur le Parlement a reçu mardi 30
janvier le rapport du gouvernement ayant
pour but de proposer une nouvelle
méthode de calcul de la retraite de base
des non salariés
agricoles ce rapport est censé dessiner
les contours d'une réforme devant
intervenir d'ici à
2026 contrairement au souhait du
législateur les trois scénarios de
réforme esquissés par le gouvernement
feraient une proportion significative de
perdant par rapport au mode de calcul
actuel Pascal grunny rapporteur du texte
pour le Sénat l'an dernier avait
pourtant fait de l'absence de perdant
une condition cineéquanone à l'adoption
de la réforme c'est pourquoi dès le
lendemain de la réception du rapport
mercredi 31 janvier Philippe Mouillet
président de la commission des affaires
sociales a présenté une proposition de
loi portant une réforme alternative
garantissant qu'aucun agriculteur ne
sera laésé en pleine crise agricole le
texte déposé par Philippe Mouillet
traduit la volonté du Sénat d'apporter
une réponse concrète au malaise de nos
agriculteurs qui doivent pouvoir
profiter d'une retraite convenable c'est
maintenant au gouvernement d'assumer ses
responsabilités pour en savoir plus
rendez-vous sur le site internet du
Sénat